FOR MORE WE'RE JOINED BY SENIOR
BLACK CORRESPONDENT AND HOST OF
THE UPCOMING "NIGHTLY SHOW WITH
LARRY WILLMORE."
MR. LARRY WILLMORE. NICE TO SEE
YOU.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. I'M EXCITED
ABOUT "THE NIGHTLY SHOW."
>> THANK YOU.
>> Jon: I'M EXCITED. I'M EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
>> "THE NIGHTLY SHOW," WHEN DOES
THAT START?
>> Jon: I BELIEVE ACTUALLY
JANUARY 19TH.
>> OH YES.
MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY.
I HAVE A JOB.
>> Jon: LARRY, IF I MAY.
THERE'S BEEN SOME TALK THAT NONE
OF THESE EVENTS OF THE PAST FEW
WEEKS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN ABOUT
RACE.
>> THE REAL EPIDEMIC IS YOUNG
BLACK MEN KILLING OTHER YOUNG
BLACK MEN.
>> 93% OF BLACKS ARE SHOT BY
OTHER BLACKS. THEY'RE KILLING
EACH OTHER THEY DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT. WHEN DO YOU HEAR
THEM TALK ABOUT, HOW DO WE
REDUCE THE CRIME.
>> Jon: WELL, YOU KNOW, LARRY,
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE?
>>OH I DON'T KNOW, JON. I WOULD
SAY THEY SHOULD PROBABLY
GO [BEEP] THEMSELVES. MAYBE?
>> Jon: I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
>> WELL NO, JON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: ALRIGHT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, CAN WE QUIT
CALLING IT BLACK ON BLACK CRIME.
IT'S JUST CRIME, OKAY.
I MEAN, BLACK ON BLACK
JUST MAKES IT SOUND LIKE
A CATEGORY ON RED TUBE. THAT'S
A PORN SITE, JON.
>> Jon: OH, THAT'S A -- OH
YES, THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S A --
>> YOU HAVE IT BOOKMARKED.
Jon: DO I HAVE IT BOOKMARKED?
I ONLY BOOKMARK IT SO I CAN PICK
UP WHERE I LEFT OFF IN THE
STORY.
>> WHERE DID YOU LEAVE OFF?
Jon: THEY WERE [BEEP].
[LAUGHING]
SO, SPOILER ALERT.
I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU HOW IT
ENDS BUT GET A TOWEL.
YOU DON'T THINK A CONVERSATION
ABOUT BLACK ON BLACK CRIME
SHOULD BE HAPPENING NOW?
>> IT IS, JON.
BUT IT'S A BLACK ON BLACK
CONVERSATION.
I MEAN, JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
HEARING IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
GO TO ANY BLACK CHURCH ON A
SUNDAY.
>> Jon: WELL THAT'S -- SEE, I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THAT
CONVERSATION. COULD I LISTEN TO
IT SOME TIME?
>> SURE WHICH BLACK CHURCH DO
YOU ATTEND, BROTHER?
>> Jon: I TWO GO TO THE FIRST
TEMPLE BAPTIST BLACK CHURCH.
>> THAT'S OKAY, JON.
I DON'T GO EITHER.
>> Jon: OH, ALRIGHT. THANK YOU.
>> BUT IT'S NOT LIKE BLACK
CRIMINALS ARE THE ONLY THING
KILLING BLACK PEOPLE.
DIABETES, STROKE AND HEART
DISEASE ARE KICKING
BLACK ON BLACK CRIME'S ASS.
OKAY?
BUT NOBODY IS SAYING WE NEED TO
GET GET RID OF THOSE BEFORE
WE CAN TALK ABOUT RACISM.
>> Jon: WELL SO, DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE ARE USING THIS ARGUMENT
AS A WAY TO INVALIDATE THE
RIGHTEOUS NATURE OF ANY OF THE
PROTESTS.
>> WELL, JON. PEOPLE ARE USING A
LOT OF ARGUMENTS TO INVALIDATE
THE PROTESTS.
>> THE PROTESTERS WHO DID NOT
LOOT OR BURN OR ASSAULT THE
POLICE BUT WHO REMAINED IN
THE FRAY ARE GUILTY OF AIDING
AND ABETTING THOSE WHO DID BY
PROVIDING THEM COVER AND
SUPPORT. IT SET BACK
RACE RELATIONS IN AMERICA YEARS.
THE VIOLENT PROTESTS
ACTUALLY CREATED MORE
BIAS AGAINST BLACKS.
[BOOING]
>> [BEEP]
MORE BIAS AGAINST BLACK
PEOPLE.
OH, NO BLACK PEOPLE, WE WERE SO
CLOSE.
WHAT DID YOU DO? STUPID BLACK
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A DREAM, JON.
THAT ONE DAY THE ACTIONS OF A
FEW [BLEEP] WHITE PEOPLE WILL BE
SEEN AS
DISCREDITING THEIR ENTIRE RACE.
>> Jon: WELL, EVERYONE KEEPS
MAKING EXCUSES.
BE IT CRIME OR OTHER ISSUES.
FOR WHY WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT
RACISM.
OR WHY IT'S NOT RACISM.
HOW DO WE END RACISM?
>> JON, WE WON'T END IT.
THE WORLD HAS ALWAYS BEEN LIKE
THIS.
BROTHER AGAINST
BROTHER. TRIBE AGAINST TRIBE.
IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO GO AWAY.
IT'S PART OF OUR DNA.
WE'RE RACEAHOLICS, JON.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE IN RECOVERY .
THE BEST WE CAN HOPE FOR IS TO
MANAGE IT.
>> Jon: SO, I GUESS WE'RE NEVER
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET THAT
30-DAY CHIP ARE WE?
>> 30 DAY CHIP? WE CAN'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE A
PROBLEM. I MEAN, WE'RE NOT EVEN
AT THE MEETING YET.
WE'RE STILL LYING IN A POOL OF
OUR OWN VOMIT GOING, I'M FINE,
I'M FINE. JUST GOTTA -- I'LL BE
OKAY.
>> Jon: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
LARRY. LARRY WILMORE, EVERYBODY.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.